for
[Music]
we want to establish an amazing Masid
for the sake of Allah subhana in the
country of Norway click on the link and
donate now for the sake of Allah subhana
tala brothers and sisters and dear
friends so as you guys know the good
news aldah of the ceasefire that has
been should we say semi agreed or
whatever for that matter as far as I
know they agreed with says is not last
Trump says it's not going to last
however still there is a ceasefire it
was agreed terms were agreed upon
hostages have been released people are
celebrating and this is a big big
embarrassment for the quote unquote
superow that is Israel that said we're
going to wipe them out we're going to
wipe out Hamas we're going to destroy
them all we're going to Humble them all
they Generations are going to remember
remember what that they gave up exactly
so the only they've been wiping their
backsides that's what they've been doing
systematically so there's some videos
it's very funny actually you know what
the funny thing is about this is
that nice all right so I'm going to show
some videos where the KET members are
literally crying bro no way they lit bro
you cannot make one on the wall crying I
want you to show you this cuz it's it's
hilarious that's even more pathetic than
than I initially hilarious like this is
going to bring coolness to everyone's
heart brother sister like you're going
to love every single second of this yeah
okay so let's go to the uh first one
first this is on the uh Israeli news
this is I don't know who this individual
is but this is what you have to
say for
that's that's the first one they they is
basically saying Hamas has won the war
yeah okay Hamas has won the war now the
second one is the reaction of when the
ceasefire actually happened so this is
this is this is the reaction of the
knesset members crying
bro he's he can make this stuff up bro
look look look look look look look look
got Kleenex in his hand got Kleenex in
his hand well that woman looks like
she's lost a child may may Allah make
them cry more look at this bro look at
this a oh we couldn't kill more kids and
children and babies look who who cries
and the exactly Bro Look at bro bro you
can't make this stuff up yet so Subhan
Allah like to me just brings joy to see
that all of the fs and this is just like
if you think about they're a superpower
well backed by a superpower yes um and
they have all kind of Technology bro
they've got bunker busling bombs bro and
guess what what bro the the um who is
that guy blinkin whatever his name is in
in America he said that they have they
Hamas has
recruited more members than it lost
brother like if you said if Israel came
and said you know what we've abolished
or de demolished half or 30% of H
remember the 40,000 killed they said oh
nearly 20,000 Hamas members yeah brother
what what are you telling me now you're
telling me they have recruited more
meaning they've become stronger Israel's
that's why you should never speak big
number two make big promises yes okay
like for example oh we're going to
toally destroy them no you did not not
only that you've caused them to recruit
more and now you are crying like little
weasles and what are you crying about
the majority of the people that you
killed were men women and children I
remember there was a clip of this Rabbi
who was saying that these guys they're
very different from the other enemies
that we've had because these guys
they're very strong with their resolve
in God and because of that we're going
to have to change our strategy we can't
just simply do this and just bomb them
and do this and do that there's an IDE
ideological war that's happening over
here as well and there was a clip on Fox
as well where he was saying that who is
the biggest threat is it China is it
Russia well uh is it George Soros well
he's being motivated by money they're
being motivated by politics or money and
then he said the Muslims or Islam is
motivated by Faith by belief in God and
he says God trumps money all day every
day cuz the purpose is greater it's it's
it's an eternal purpose it's not finite
like money or whatever it is and that's
the reason why they block Tik Tok they
are afraid of the Palestinians but if
you think about it the biggest world
superpower with all his Technology power
soldiers army are scared of the
Palestinians and this just makes not
only the Palestinian cause more greater
more Global more stronger more focused
and this they've lost a battle in all
kind of areas all kind of grounds public
opinion oh for sure bro it's it's
devastating everybody has heard about
Palestine everybody devastating a
generation of brain rot Genies that were
just
on their social media playing games
morning evening everybody even these
guys have been made aware of what's
going on in Palestine Palestine now with
social media it was a broadcasted
genocide something but happened in
history for it to be documented to this
level in 4k and Subhan Allah like
brothers and sisters like and it was
hell on Earth in fact the ninth un
leader Antonio gz actually says if you
want to see hell on Earth look at the
children of Gaza the Red Cross describes
it as a sinking ship hell on Earth
though hell now on Earth you know what I
mean like when you're seeing we've
become desensitized desensitized to
these words of kids with limbs missing
and this and that it came to a point
that people just just couldn't watch
that stuff you know you're radicalizing
an entire generation of people and now
what's happened is
it it still hasn't ended exactly and it
will never uh end in the space and again
look they've they l p the battle on
social media public opinion they have
increased anti-Semitism which again we
do not condone there should not be
anti-Semitism like I I be very upfront
with this matter this anti-Semitism is
interesting because they they say like
who are semites the Arabs are semites so
if Arabs are semites as well when you're
saying this person is an anti-semite it
means they they're going against
uh that person is going against at least
13 Nations so that doesn't make sense
either and you know what we need this
term islamist this term anti-semite we
need to really hone in on these words I
think we take it for granted too much
yeah you know what I mean yeah they have
and they've lost that that value that
antisemitism help because it's like
they've use in people are just being
like okay this is a reporting happened
kids have died you're anti-semitic if
you use it everywhere in that manner you
are losing the value of it and Israel
has caused more anti-Semitism than
anyone can for that matter and again
like I said before we're against anyone
we shouldn't no one should come and
blame Jews and every Jew for that that's
not because as Muslims we get that label
oh it's all Muslims so we are against
that this is Zionism guys this is
Zionism there are many many amazing
Jewish rabbis Rabbi Beck from Stanford
Hill that have met in person um these
guys dedication on the Sabbath where
they could not even drive a car they
came to the protest we we offered to
drop them back home they said we cannot
go in a car and I was thinking hold on a
second but we're in bow in East London
to walk to Stanford Hill is like 1 and a
half hour 2 hours bro they like no we're
going to walk back cardio bro bro that's
next level cardio yeah and but it just
shows you the cardio of their Humanity
it's more stronger than the cardio of um
you know their body should we say so we
just want to say guys hulah it is so
amazing I'll be honest I just love
seeing them cry I hope they cry more I
hope they cry they are crying like they
lost a child yeah they are crying like
they lost a child you we the ones that
lost kids we're the ones that lost
mothers and father let tell you
something who who did you lose exactly
and look at the of the Palestinians
comparison to the Palestinians exactly
look at the attitude of the
Palestinians exactly and not only that
people are flocking to Islam because of
this win win win bro win win win it's
like the treaty ofia it looked like when
allaha in the Quran reveal Surah fat yes
and we have given you a clear Victory
when you look at it you're like where is
the victory we are seeing that Victory
now for the Palestine people and may
Allah subhana tala free them from the
shackles of this regime and we hope that
Palestine goes back goes back to
Palestinians inshah that they can live
how they lived with the Christians and
the Jews um together as Muslims for
centuries yes so when antiem real
antisemitism that came from the
Crusaders and when they took over
Palestine they made sure Jews Fri there
because the Christians hated the Jews
yes brought 40 or 80 Jewish families
back there so they can live in harmony
so this anti-Semitism is absolute
nonsense that we are blamed for that so
hope you guys enjoy this guys hope it
brought corers to your eyes and your
heart may Allah subh make them cry more
let them cry even more uh and Allah is
dealing with them in all different ways
inshallah um and yeah that's all we have
to say in brother sisters um if there's
any more videos like this that we would
like I would I love reacting this kind
of stuff yeah the last one we' done with
Muhammad hijab and yourself was you know
when they're crying at the grave my son
my brother went to kill more woman and
children and he and and you know what's
what's even more crazy like after all
this they invited Elon Musk all the way
there to Israel they tried to they tried
reel back X and they tried to do all of
this the amount of information that has
come out on X
exposing viciously exposing the
connections Israel has in America that
it's had with the likes of Michael
Jackson with Tupac in the rap industry
whether it's black people and that that
rap industry whether it's pop with
Michael Jackson whether it's JFK people
are talking about Donald Trump The
Laughing uh
well yeah I mean that that there was
somebody that I was speaking to Ben
Shapiro and he was saying oh what about
those dancing um Israelis so what's
interesting here is the cherry on the
cake just now when we're seeing Donald
Trump become the next prime minister or
rather the president of the United
States and we see Elon Musk celebrating
how did Elon Musk celebrate yeah yeah
that's what he done bro literally he
went and
unanimously it's agreed that that is a
Nazi now I believe he's an alien you
know they said he might be an alien but
here's the thing though I what the hell
was that but somebody did a little
parody of Ben Shapiro reacting to that
and seeing and goes oh uh um I don't
know what what he did there maybe there
was an accident he's not going to do oh
he's done it again now oh he's he's
turning around and doing it again what
Ben well somebody did a parody of
someone pretending to be Ben reacting to
it um so so that's the thing it's like
Israel is getting its butt slapped in
any direction that it turns even with
Elon Musk who they invested so much in
the guy pretty much did a Nazi salute
people are trying to say oh no it's a
Roman salute no there's no video
evidence that Romans would salute like
that and James O'Brien made a very good
point he goes yeah okay that really then
next time you're at work do that salute
yeah and don't say anything and see what
people say go out do that salute record
yourself upload it do that salute and
see what people say only the the right
wing would defend the likes of B even
when he's doing a salute like that let's
give a real proper salute to the
Palestinians who survived this war at
losing family members children aldah and
they are the true Victors inshallah and
may Allah humiliate um the zist regime
and inshallah see its end soon brother
sisters
[Music]